[Música]
oi eu sou o guilherme santos ribeiro tem
11 anos estudo do 5º ano e hoje vou
falar sobre a teto literária mas você
sabe acabar tertúlia literária até turnê
literária é quando as pessoas se reúnem
e cobertor sobre o livro cobre a classe
ela está reunida em círculo para ver
melhor quem está acobertando a escola à
comunidade temos essa atividade que
realizamos com freqüências que consiste
da leitura os livros clássicos da
literatura e do compartilhamento de
trechos selecionados pelos alunos com
foco e chamou a atenção o que faz
lembrar a situação vista houve vida é um
exercício de reflexão de comunicação e
de escrita
durante a leitura do livro é possível
perceber que nosso olhar está atento que
tocar nosso coração ou bens que são
esses trechos que colbert comentou da
tertúlia
outro ponto a ser ressaltado a qui das
atividades melhorando suas habilidades
de argumentação do autor o nosso
envolvimento quando tentamos
compartilhar algo novo que demonstra uma
visão diferente sobre uma mesma questão
o último livro lido por minha classe foi
alice no país das maravilhas e toy e
portanto com esse texto trouxe à tona e
desce nas saladas adolescência roberto
tão presente em nossas vidas
idéias como agressividade egoísmo
ganância tempo e ignorância medo loucura
foram abordados pelo grupo deixou
exemplo seu comentário que o filho do
livro alice no país das maravilhas
o que acho que eu selecionei foi tirado
da página 54 do 3º parágrafo que diz o
gato viu ali se deu amplo sorriso
parecia meio bem humorado mas suas
garras eram bem grandes
ele tinha muitos dentes futebol do que
ela achou melhor tratado com respeito e
o meu comentário foi alice como o gato
sorriso e ver que ele parece feroz mas
as aparências enganam roubado meu pai
ele parece cérebro
avança na verdade o contrário o grupo
cresce durante todo o processo da
tertúlia as pessoas perdem o medo de
falar aprender a opinar ea respeitar a
idéia do outro
desenvolvemos a paciência com as pessoas
elas só vez ea capacidade de ouvir
colega refletir sobre aquele assunto
temos algo a mais a dizer
melhoramos a nossa leitura escrita e
descobrimos novas palavras
até tu é muito importante pois hoje em
dia as pessoas dois tubos ligados ao
real e se ao virtual através de tablets
celulares que games etc
por fim sabemos através dos professores
que os grupos que trabalham com a teoria
literária a cada ano escolar melhoram
suas colocações e eu sei disso porque
porque utilizo mais recursos daí tele
gência e da criatividade para conseguir
bons argumentos
obrigado
[Aplausos]